- Salud.
Adrenal cocktails like this one
are supposed to help with
something called adrenal fatigue.
Its symptoms include trouble sleeping,
salt and sugar cravings,
body aches, depression,
anxiety and brain fog.
But the most common is feeling tired.
Influencers' unsubstantiated claims
suggest that these small glands
are getting out of balance.
They swear that regularly
taking these cocktails
or taking adrenal supplements
is the answer to getting these
glands back in top shape.
But do these DIY Cocktails
or over the counter
supplements actually work?
On social media,
people are saying that the main
culprit for adrenal fatigue
is chronic stress.
More specifically, the way
it makes the adrenal glands
crank out a lot of cortisol,
a stress hormone.
The theory is that over time,
this overproduction fatigues the adrenals
and decreases their
ability to make cortisol,
and then we end up feeling
fatigued or even unmotivated.
The hormone isn't just related to stress.
It's also critical for basic functions
like regulating blood
pressure and sugar levels.
That's what the combo
of OJ, coconut water,
sea salt and cream of tartar
is supposed to combat.
Coconut water and cream of
tartar are high in potassium,
an electrolyte that's involved
in maintaining healthy blood pressure.
sea salt contains sodium,
another important electrolyte
that the body uses
to keep muscles and
nerves working properly
and to stay hydrated.
And OJ has vitamin C,
which is an important antioxidant.
All this sounds pretty good, right?
But.
- We do not have any evidence
to support that this specific
combination of ingredients
supports the adrenal glands specifically.
- Or that these ingredients
affect the amount of
hormones they produce.
Priya also said
that for people with kidney
disease or high blood pressure,
the high amounts of potassium
in coconut water and cream of tartar
could actually be harmful,
and the sugar from
juicing is also not great,
especially if you're prone
to or already have diabetes.
Given levels of stress
and anxiety arising,
this trend makes sense.
- So when patients come to me
asking about adrenal cocktails,
they're hoping to improve
their energy levels,
potentially improve libido,
and just improve their
overall sense of wellbeing.
- She and other hormone specialists
say that it's not as simple
as just looking at cortisol levels.
They naturally go up and down
depending on a lot of
factors like time of day
and whether you've eaten.
The tiredness and other
symptoms people experience
could be caused by a
variety of health issues.
- Adrenal fatigue is not
considered a medical disease,
but your symptoms should
be considered and be heard.
- Now, there is a
similarly named condition
called adrenal insufficiency
with a list of symptoms
that will sound familiar.
Patients report fatigue, muscle weakness,
joint pain, loss of appetite,
craving salty foods and depression.
But this condition is pretty rare.
The most common type
effects somewhere between
50,000 and 92,000 people
in the U.S.
By comparison,
there are more than 6 million
people with Alzheimer's
and roughly 37 million with diabetes.
Supplements are also a common way
that people try to boost
their adrenal health,
and this is where things can backfire.
Most cases of adrenal insufficiency happen
when patients stop taking corticosteroids,
which are anti-inflammatory drugs.
In 2018, researchers found
that 12 popular adrenal
supplements contained hormones,
including cortisol and glucocorticoids,
AKA corticosteroids.
They did this study after noticing
that patients with adrenal
insufficiency symptoms
had one big thing in
common, taking supplements.
None of the labels had these
hormones listed as ingredients.
- You don't know what's
actually inside the supplement.
- If you don't have adrenal insufficiency,
long-term exposure to corticosteroids
can actually harm your adrenals.
Manufacturers are only legally required
to include this disclaimer
on their labels.
In the last two years,
the FDA has sent a
handful of warning letters
to adrenal supplement vendors
over the claims their products are making.
The burden of proof that a
supplement might be causing harm
falls to the U.S. Government.
The experts I talked to
said that before taking any supplement,
you should talk to your doctor.
They also worry that
self-prescribing adrenal cocktails
might actually delay
getting at the root cause
of what people are feeling.
Doctors also said
that we shouldn't discount
basic but underrated activities
that boost our health.
- You need to walk.
You need to get your movement in.
You need to exercise.
You need to sleep.
Stay hydrated.
Manage and reduce your stress.
Eat a balanced diet.
- [Daniela] And all of that
might get you further
towards a healthier life
than a mocktail or a pill.
(gentle music)